i am oh for four i'm guessing what these  woke commercials are actually selling so  i'm going to try again  hey the guy's a boss  a woman is bossy oh  yeah poor women anyways because one of  these  one of these feminism commercials okay  so he's persuasive  she's pushy yeah that's it women have it  so hard in this country  that's why they live longer and make up  most college students right  because of how hard they have it you  know she's selfish  [Music]  neat and vain oh yeah  yeah we never give women credit for  their physical beauty no never not in  this country  she's a show-off yeah wow  pantene prophy  shampoo wants you to know that we live  in a patriarchy and women  can't get anything and women are always  put down and criticized and men are  always exalted as so wonderful